[Music]
this program shows drugs being made sold
and used it features graphic content
that may not be suitable for all
audiences viewer discretion is advised
welcome to Detroit
I call it the same city bro cause every
day is like happening
there's one time of year when Anarchy
rules and the Motor City drug dealers
have to make a killing
Halloween
in Detroit the Rave Scene goes crazy
they want to pop drugs non-stop
it's nasty out here
Halloween makes more money than
Christmas does over a frantic 48 Hours
the police are clamping down and the
dealers are tooling up y'all have a gun
with me I'm not ready to stop what I'm
doing right now for Devil's Night with a
difference it's like the devil will be
over Detroit
[Music]
once the crown jewel of American
industry two-thirds of Detroit's
population has left the city
[Music]
high unemployment
[Music]
some see dealing as a matter of survival
[Music]
now as the city recovers from bankruptcy
holidays like Halloween offer an excuse
for those detroiters looking to escape
their woes and a chance for dealers
looking to score
[Music]
hustle later Detroit
that's all we do every day like you have
blue collar hustle you got white catalog
so you got the street hustle everybody's
hustling 24 7 365 in Detroit
Rhino runs a gang of six Street dealers
to supply a variety of drugs look at
ecstasy pills Heron we got up acid got
weed of course anything you desire we
can get it for you
it's the day before Halloween and
Rhino's last delivery has just arrived
most profitable drug was uh cocaine
he's bought two and a half kilos
we are generally getting cocaine in
Chicago we bring it in break it down
distribute it in the places we needed to
have it at
during Halloween times it picks up it
gets a little bit crazy you know users
need what they need so we Supply
Rhino hopes to double his money by
earning fifty thousand dollars over the
next two days increase as we go money
grows we just try to buy more product
and expand it's always expansion is on
the agenda
but for Rhino to move volume he has to
put pressure on his dealers
come on he has to come back and the name
of the game is give it a product as fast
as you can or you can end up you know in
a river somewhere
the drugs and games come with a
territory in Detroit and the violence
you know is inevitable and is going on
constantly
although authorities are starting to
clean up the city money is scarce and
the job is huge nearly 80 000 derelict
buildings meanwhile provide perfect
cover for the drug trade
Rhino's best street dealer will use this
cover to sell a half a kilo of cocaine
over Halloween
gotta get that money with this will take
you out the head and it puts you in
prison too but hey it's a chance to be
taking
this is the spot that somewhere we know
is open but we patrolling our block
because you got another vacant one
across the street
I picked the situation I'm gonna put it
somewhere they ain't gonna go
I get that phone call they need it I
know why I put it up
only I know where I put it at
Jelly Bean knows this old building well
they're giving me the cheers
it was his childhood home
as you look at a knives burnt down
bombed out but it just used to be
beautiful
his family used to deal drugs out of it
until a rival gang tried to take over
Neighborhood Cats In The Hood jealous
because they can't get the good product
like they want to get
tried to burn this out
shot through the front window as you see
the bullet holes right there come on
my father he was laying on the couch
and threw the fire bomb through the back
window they wanted him to run out
through this door but he was smart
because he's around the door they would
have killed him
they try to kill us but they couldn't
stop us
[Music]
Jelly Bean Halloween is an opportunity
to cash in but he has to be careful
another word can be dangerous
yo knew behind that mask
I don't know if he's trying to get you
the devil's lighting numbers
[Applause]
in the 1980s and 90s Halloween in
Detroit became notorious for arson
but locals fought back to protect the
streets and abandoned buildings
we do not have to keep destroying our
neighborhood
it now means the police can concentrate
on fighting other crimes
not that Jelly Bean is concerned
I ain't worried about the police dealers
just don't give up
he ready to shoot Rob and Tate to get
his Hustle they can't control
if I want to sell my sack right here
that's what I do
Jelly Bean deals around the infamous
Eight Mile Road it's a dividing line
to the South the dealers in inner city
Detroit
to the north the users in more affluent
suburbs
in the middle
the police
they take away the drug dealer we can
take away the user all of it's a battle
we try and eliminate all of it
with Detroit police low on resources it
often comes down to the Suburban forces
to catch the dealers
first the dealers have to step into
their jurisdiction
a lot of our dealers stay in Detroit
come and meet their subjects on it now
they won't even cross the border the
team uses Undercovers to set up eyes
even though Street dealers are getting
wise these dealers know if you're a cop
and they'll sniff you out and know
something's not right
but yeah we see something that looks
suspicious or something what's wrong to
get out of there
the undercover officer for UC is parked
up on the Suburban side of the Eight
Mile Road
yo what's up man
and is on the phone to the dealer oh no
no no no no no way bro nearby units are
listening in and are ready to pounce at
the slightest sign of danger
ous
is trying to change the location of the
deal right now
we need that Greed for him to make that
money
to overcome the fear across an Eight
Mile and that's the cat Mouse game that
we're always battling you know with all
these dealers
he's gotta take that gamble no I see you
my angel always you know that
dealers getting suspicious you ready for
a foot chase
it's still over here
nobody's gonna suspect sticks to Roar
Knuckles this doesn't work out we'll
take him down
[Music]
I don't know if you want to try to take
him there or not getting position
rollerball with me
to act fast before the dealer slips back
into Detroit and out of their
jurisdiction
[Music]
without evidence it'll be hard to bust
them
he threw something down back there guys
hey I
won how many rocks
we have watched him pitch this
cellophane wrapper to the ground he
didn't acknowledge even having this than
what we're talking about but we recover
it and there's your crack cocaine
one dealer down
in Detroit much of the drug dealing
happens in small gangs or clicks based
in one area
it's hoods and without a gang City
who is stick together ain't no colors
around here
it's about the money green
and because we represent green
Jelly Bean prefers to deal cocaine with
people he knows
internet connection
you're gonna take a chance but I ain't
gonna take too many of them
we keep it in a circle man and Halloween
is a big opportunity to cash in
well Halloween time everybody want to
get high you got to prepare for it they
want it all
if you want the money you go make sure
you got it while parties happen
throughout October they build to a
frenzy on Halloween night what's up baby
girl
that means getting the drugs partygoers
want in advance no I ain't got no
mollies I hit you up if I get some just
keep your phone on all right one
Molly or pure MDMA is a powerful
stimulant its effects can last for up to
six hours
while jelly beans cocaine is traffic
from South America via Chicago
party drugs like Molly come in from the
north
Detroit is the only major U.S city with
its downtown on the Canadian border the
perfect spot for onward distribution and
local retail
can you take one of these triple Stacks
even be in 18 20 hours barely any cut on
them you up full go one pill
Street dealer Ziggy and Casper claim to
specialize in some of the strongest
party drugs in Detroit
I like to clicking the fast money
my Molly's pure MDMA no cut straight
straight from Canada
and then my ex is probably my step down
once
you notice the dark color that means
it's cut with a with like a downer it's
gonna bring you down your crash is going
to be a lot harder but you're going to
be up a long time before that crash hits
you you gotta hydrate and you want you
gotta hydrate otherwise you might
explode
blood boil
we read up I say last Sunday going to
the week over Halloween their product is
in high demand we had three jars of
these oh yeah about 300 pills and then
we had two ounces of the Molly this is
what's left to everything
cheesy money man
but they're still waiting for new
supplies I got eight left I was gonna go
drop off five it's one of my homies
while they only deal party drugs in
Detroit no one takes chances
even to be no robbing me
I go nuts for mine
Troy the day before Halloween
Molly dealer Ziggy and Casper Head West
into the suburbs
[Music]
students are their best customers
[Music]
your kids here who are filthy rich
because Mommy and Daddy are doctors they
got money to blow every night anywhere
from the nerd in his room all night to
the football player who just scored all
the touchdowns
they're all doing it pretty much every
day these kids are out here again
[Music]
she rocks steady baby won't you
kill always looking to expand you know
we're bump into like a girl like her I
walk up on a what's up play a little
roll for a minute what's up what you
doing today oh yeah where's the parties
at tonight oh yeah well I'll give him
like a free one right there sometimes if
I got it on me just lose oh yeah we all
everyone does that I get my number and
then after that they call they keep
calling
they split up to cover the area
[Music]
follow me
up 300.
[Music]
hey money money money kids want to do
drugs go crazy
so around right around this time of
month come up here and just get it off
everything go
when it comes to Halloween Ziggy and
Casper are looking to cash in
damn Halloween in Detroit the Rave Scene
goes crazy it's nasty out here the
party's just non-stop they want to pop
drugs so it's just action all through
October
miss Halloween I hope to make at least
15 000 for my pocket and go back to the
store come right back make some more
a profitable Halloween will allow them
to step up their operation
[Music]
still waiting for fresh supplies
stocks in the city are low thanks to a
recent bust we had a huge one just north
of here which was a huge ecstasy bust
National aircraft at fluid from Canada a
low flyer
it's cbp's job to stop the drugs coming
over from Canada Detroit sector is kind
of a unique sector within all of the
United States
we're being a complete water border with
Canada
so patrolling this area is a difficult
task
if someone wanted to come across the
border bringing drugs there's so many
different places that they can access
as we get a little bit South we're about
to go see one of the busiest Crossings
in the United States
the Ambassador Bridge in Detroit is the
busiest commercial Crossing on the
northern border it makes finding drug
traffickers even tougher
it's just the sheer mass amount of
numbers they see on a daily basis
very difficult job we have to win every
day that we're out here bad guys they
only win once
above the traffic the patrol can spot
any drivers behaving suspiciously
across the border
sometimes I get pulled over anything you
know sometimes the cops they just
messaged you for no reason but if you're
doing a speed limit you know what you
got to do everything should be good
cuckoo started trafficking three years
ago at first it was scary but I needed
extra money take care of my kids
and I was like oh I'm gonna do it for a
minute and I'm gonna get out of it I
could never get out of it
I make 3 000 a trip
four trips a month
it's fast money you need fast money
that's what you do
30 hours till the big Halloween Raves
and her Connections in Detroit are
keeping her busier than ever
she's in Canada heading to the bridge
it's her fourth trip in two weeks
gonna be the busiest
everybody having parties and carrying on
Halloween
makes more money than Christmas does
so
Halloween is big
Wing more trips could raise suspicion
I'm about to pull up to the bridge
she's got to be extra careful
all three seat belt you know make sure
your mirror is good
I was using blinkers whenever you turn
the left or right
camera now
[Music]
at the Detroit border with Canada
just visiting my sister I had it back
home it's the day before Halloween
drug trafficker cuckoo is busy
she's attempting her fourth trip across
in just two weeks
thank you
have a good day
what makes her a popular trafficker is
that she prefers not to know exactly
what she's bringing in I prefer not to
know I mean it could be money it could
be drugs it could be anything
follow the instructions I'm giving
on this trip she's making a dead drop
and doesn't even know who the package is
for
they just tell me where to go
drop off
I get my money
Go On by my life
today's drop is Molly
and with the shortage in the city it's
not long before it's picked up
[Music]
[Music]
on my way
upstairs I can get 84 percent good
before being acetone washed
serious MD I mean you can get in Detroit
Mountain's a middleman
collecting from traffickers and then
selling in bulk to Street dealers
it's the value of my product it's
eighteen hundred dollars an ounce the
more you pick up the better deal I give
you
the longer you're around the better deal
I gave you
[Music]
the latest delivery must be up to
standard
or as Street dealers won't pay full
price
right here the whole ounce and you
prefer it to be interacts of course
there is some powder in there
I will show you how crystallized it is
customers will be happy with your ex
then we're probably just because they
know that it is real
test I'm going to use is uh monkey
on the scale we wanted to pass dark blue
should take about two seconds to react
[Music]
I see how quick is reacting
[Music]
is
dark blue almost black
which is actually a great day because of
how quick it turned
said it is 84 without being acetone
washed
often Mali dealers like to add other
chemicals to their product in order to
stretch it
[Music]
the dispatch is nearly pure some people
cut it with Coke or Vicodin heroin and
it's the worst feeling in the world you
know and then she said to your stomach
you want to be literally until I could
die and message because they're greedy
and they want more money and you know
you're risking your customers lives
which is the one thing you don't want to
do
how are you going to give money when
your customer is dead
but now we don't have to worry about
getting greedy because you buy an ounce
for 1800
you can flick that entire ounce for 2800
almost stumbling your money at least
once you get free it starts when you get
caught
[Music]
the Night Before Halloween and border
patrol is stepping up its watch
[Music]
we see ecstasy coming from Canada
you know whether they're mixing in five
gallon pails in the garage or or what
you know that's that's the danger
these individuals are playing kind of a
drug Russian Roulette
[Music]
certainly is Halloween the party time
that you'll see a greater usage locally
since he last appeared on drugs Inc Mark
Hall and his team have seized over 1.5
million dollars worth of drugs we're
gonna head to the area where we've seen
the smuggling in the past it's a pretty
active spot definitely some cross-border
Nexus
marks on the lookout for anyone
trafficking drugs into or around the
city he's heard talk of a new batch of
Molly in town we always have to be
prepared
unfortunately I've seen the results of
some of this with some of the Ecstasy in
Bali where it's actually caused death
here in Detroit
[Music]
[Applause]
Molly distributor Mountain has just
picked up a new Consignment from Canada
we prefer to stay off the road as much
as possible
the more you're on the road the sooner
someone's going to catch on
I would rather not have some cop pull me
over and get one of the biggest thoughts
of his life
Mountain prefers to stay out of sight
and in control but it's almost Halloween
and he's got to get the drugs to his
dealers all the people I deal with I've
known for years
before I even sell to you I need address
where you work at because you know an
awesome guy can come up to you and be
the cops
yeah this guy's driving real kind of
goofy down here we're at Dearborn and
Harbaugh
I'm gonna light them up
[Music]
it's the Night Before Halloween and
Detroit border patrol Agent Mark Hall
has just pulled over a car
I don't lie good your driver's license
Paul spotted something wait why don't
you put your hands where I can see I'm
okay I need you to step out of the
vehicle okay go ahead and keep your
hands out your pockets
across town
Mali distributor mountain is still one
step ahead of the law
one always makes me aware I want to be
it's always on my team so I can feel
safer so I can scoop out the air before
you even get there
for him it's all about control
I talked with this and saw you don't
bring it back to me
up will be next week
mountains work is done
but for agent Hall he's got to go
everywhere in here dude the night has
just begun straw consistent with use for
cocaine
a lot of paraphernalia in here
and more marijuana in here
these things are delivering is what
they're doing
yeah right you know you sold seven
thousand dollars worth of weed tonight
is what you've done yes and you're still
out here slinging
I may be old but I can still spot a bad
guy
[Music]
listen breaking out of these walls
it's finally Halloween morning in
Detroit the distributor's job is done
now the pressure switches to the street
dealers
[Music]
when it comes to Halloween Jelly Bean
has a new tactic cash in on the party
goers downtown with pure cocaine and
marijuana
when you come to Detroit you're going to
look for some weed you're gonna look for
some cocaine you gonna look for the
extra pills you're not gonna find it on
every corner here
party goers are usually happy to pay a
higher price and that means higher
profits
but it also means Jelly Bean is out of
his hood and on other dealers turf
you gotta stay focused because your
first time it'll be your last time
what we call these throwaways
because just in case you got to get rid
of it you can't be running with it you
can't get caught with it just throw it
away
you a new one
small handy so if I ain't sure you
wouldn't know I had it
so you got to weave your ways and make
sure you connect with the right people
there's a lot of snakes out here
I'm gonna shoot that too if I feel like
you're trying to take me out
then today I know I'm killing you but
guess what I gotta eat
[Music]
it's the night Detroit has been waiting
for Halloween
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
in the suburbs Warren Police are off to
work
they're heading to the city line known
as eight mile
the same area Jelly Bean is based
we are going to execute a search warrant
for a person who has felony warrants for
delivery of
narcotics both heroin and cocaine
the police have heard there's a street
dealer who's looking to cash in on
Halloween
suspect we're after is made of
statements in the past and you know no
one's going to arrest me and you know
please I'm not afraid of the police
The Raid team in the van directly ahead
of us
any shots fired or anything like that
just Retreats back to this vehicle
all right start rolling knuckles
[Music]
keep hitting that door
[Music]
hold there hold there
I got him
call the first floor clear
just when they think they've cleared the
house
we got a basement still they find
another door going left left right
it's Halloween in the Detroit area
and Warren Police have just raided a
suspected drug dealer's House near the
City Line basement clear
they make a shocking discovery
foreign
kids clothing and needles my favorite
combination
we have needles in three rooms
Pharmacy in here backpack was full of
those there's trails that are other
people's names prescription pills were
often used by addicts or sold to pay for
other illegal drugs
[Music]
and there's more drug paraphernalia in a
back room these are the glass stems they
use smoke the crack cocaine
set them down the front the dealer tried
to fortify the house
had a door barricaded with a couch next
to it so I had a little resistance when
I came in I hit the door but then they
had to go over to couch to get into the
house
now Sergeant sticks and his team can
clear the house
I'm not gonna leave them with pills so
yeah they can keep selling
his ass
police
somebody interrupted
[Music]
back in Detroit jelly beans leaving his
hood in search of partygoers downtown
million dollar spot
there's gonna be money down there
you will get more money down here
they've been in the hood
money flowing all the time
[Music]
pure cocaine that's the main thing
you're gonna find on me
I ain't even can't worry about
but with other dealers already working
the downtown Turf the risks are high
territorial in the city man
you gotta know what you're doing and how
to maneuver it how to get it off where's
the best place to do it
that thrilled about it because they will
cut you cut you quick
they will kill you
Robbie
take whatever they need
Jelly Bean doesn't worry about the
police when he's in his own hood
but downtown
it's a different matter
Detroit police came as they hear voting
control
crazy
across town
dealers Casper and Ziggy have picked up
the delivery of Molly
they still have 200 pills to make yeah
and the doors have already opened at
their chosen Sales spot an illegal rave
they know kids are gonna be in there off
drugs all sorts of drugs Molly
asset actually all that
but it's more or less yeah make sure
nobody's bringing no weapons in there so
they're not going to be digging all in
my balls
they're confident of getting in with the
drugs oh man we Crouch and get up in
there stick it up in my crotch walk
through security again it is the easy
part is just being alert while you're in
there
it's gonna be a busy night
calls are already coming in what up duh
how many of them you want
or
yeah I got you boom too bad
there you go
in areas of the community that money's
tight the currency that flows there is
dry
why it's only been in the job for 12
months but he's already seen some
shocking things a few months ago I
rolled up on scene it was a stock to be
a drug overdose the patient was
exhibiting flu-like symptoms and
vomiting what it actually turned out to
be is they had crushed up and snorted
bed bugs
[Music]
the city in Detroit they have a lot of
drug rolling and it calls on average 15
to 20 calls go out a night
not long before Wyatt gets a call an
AK-47 shooting just outside downtown
[Music]
let's just get him out there
but when the team goes in
they find multiple victims there's one
upstairs how bad is the other one
they've got to prioritize how bad is she
she's got bullets she seems stable I
think he's a little more serious
a man has suffered a wound to the groin
go ahead and lay back man lay back
get you out here okay
he's heavy man
I think the girls fairly said we can
take her too
the Hallmarks of a Turf War
I think I saw some bullet holes through
the front window
they're saying it was an AK-47 sounds
about right the guy's a pretty good
sized hole in his leg
patient isn't responding we'll get some
vitals and go
[Music]
so Wyatt steps on the gas
let me know when we're close
the nearest hospital is only six minutes
away they've got to race to get there
okay we're almost there before he goes
into shock what's our ETA
Detroit Halloween
paramedics Wyatt and Andrew get their
shooting victim to the hospital just in
time
he's pretty lucky the femoral already
runs right there and if you hit that and
you can bleed out pretty quickly
downtown Street dealer Jelly Bean is
also riding his luck he's trying to sell
cocaine
but he's got a problem I don't lie good
your driver's license
border patrol
it's hot as hell right now you just see
the police and the canine dogs
if it's okay now if you can't get past
them
got the building surrounded they're
investigating something some type of nut
car that's going on
so you know it's real slow
which is everybody had and getting out
the way right now
Detroit police Halloween's this season
with the police still on the street
jelly beans now lost two hours of
dealing time
man trying to find somewhere else so we
can get this paper man and I ain't about
to take no chance
[Music]
Molly dealer Ziggy and Casper have got
past security and into their Halloween
raved this down they checking out Dean
letting you go
you're offering high quality at a high
price pure as you're gonna get it down
there coming up here
but a recent batch of bad Molly has made
people reluctant to buy man
the pills that I got had all crystal
meth in it
I didn't know I ended up taking five and
that was a really bad experience I end
up staying up for three days straights I
didn't have that appetite
I had these pounding headaches I thought
it would never stop like I thought I was
just going to be a wig for seven days I
didn't sleep at all
with pills like Molly it's hard to tell
what's inside
there's this Blind Faith in the dealer
it's either made by a good chemist or a
bad chemist and if you get the good
chemists then you're golden
[Music]
[Applause]
word has finally got around about the
quality of Ziggy and Casper's Molly
straight straight from Kansas and sales
are picking up
man everybody's taking pills but the
longer they stay in one place the
greater the chance they'll get spotted
got off more than half my jab already I
should have arrested during the next
like 30 40 minutes if I just keep moving
get about this
[Music]
theirs isn't the only illegal rave on
the cops radar
border patrol responds to a call for
help from a local Detroit police force
the DJs are selling the dope and it's
coming out of the bathroom too
they're preparing for the worst
like I said we got the uc's inside so be
careful they're not armed or anything
like that because they were patting them
down when they went in
one of our UCS just made a buy I'm not
sure what yet
undercover officers inside the Rave the
team has Intel on the location but not
security any time where there's drugs
involved you're dealing with a lot of
money people tend to use guns to protect
the money protect the drugs so when they
go in
they going hard
[Music]
shut your legs out straight your legs
out
face down look at the floor don't be
looking around this ain't entertainment
keep your hands where I can see him
when I get cuffed up look at the forearm
you got any guns on you
anything that's gonna poke me stab me
they must ensure the location's safe
run right here it was under two pillows
it was loaded I just cleared it
with everyone in custody
it's got to be around here somewhere
they can begin the search for drugs yeah
well he's got a heroin huh looks like
heroin crack cocaine
we're still searching good morning
see if you can read the number on any of
these pills you didn't recognize any of
these as the tally mounts up ecstasy the
oxycodone that's going to be heroin
the team suddenly discovers someone in
the bathroom crawl up now crawl
backwards crawl backwards not move
the coke the toilet doesn't flush it
didn't work
for some
it all gets too much
[Music]
sometimes on these raids we'll see the
individuals swallow the drugs to avoid
the prosecution
[Music]
The Raid also Nets a major find where
good job guys
a new and Dangerous Drug for Detroit's
border patrol to watch out for looks
like a uh a pretty good sized piece of
crystal meth not too common here in
Detroit not common at all
walk straight over that table those
officers over there
[Music]
across town jelly beans finally found a
Halloween party and nothing better than
cocaine in the bluff but it's a house
party back in his hood meet you at the
corner
he can't charge downtown prices all
right bro gotcha so his profits will be
down have a good day
Ziggy and Casper have dodged law
enforcement at their Rave now they can
Count Their takings man came up about
like eight eight fifty out of that real
quick popping my quick little hour hour
and a half work
Still rocking here I mean there's one
little party and then we'll say the
average of all the little frat Parts
everything we'll bring in about 15.
now they'll be able to buy in bulk go
back to the career Bring up come back to
the party this party's just starting to
jump
[Music]
they're not stopping yet
[Music]
for others the party's over
the operation uh went real well we got
the three guns off the street got a lot
of drugs and uh nobody's injured either
on the perps or the police side
not a bad haul
but jelly beans Halloween hasn't been a
success a little slow night it wouldn't
like we're supposed to be you know what
it did they crack it down all the police
better you know what I'm saying just at
a world with the punches
still hoping he can bring some profits
back to his street gang
this ain't even begin it's gonna pick up
it'll be greater every day
get in get out go and take care of my
business
Jelly Bean successful Halloween isn't
about the money
it's about survival Halloween just just
crazy people have doing the Curious that
somebody dying
they're gonna shoot patch
this ain't my dreams
enemies coming from all angles actually
as long as you know you got to make it
up out of here live
it's like the dirt will be over Detroit
[Music]
that's why they call it the D
[Music]
[Music]